welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the added cost
of america's spiking inflation rate this
week the labor department reported a 9.1
percent increase in consumer prices in
june that's higher than the increase we
saw in may and the largest gain since
november of 1981. indiana jones was the
top movie that year just think about
that surging gasoline prices are part of
what's driving inflation and while that
affects every american in some way it's
especially hard on families that have to
travel long distances for necessary
medical treatment
fifteen-year-old ginger vincent's health
depends on a key calculation do we have
enough gas to do it
because we got appointments on wednesday
appointments on thursday ginger
who lives for sports was diagnosed with
bone cancer more than a year ago the
first thought that i had was don't cry
i was in front of my parents and i
wanted to be strong for them just hard
to see her that she was so healthy and
vibrant
smart
just to see her wasting away in bed
her parents keith and anna-lysa vincent
have watched ginger go through chemo and
multiple surgeries the athlete had part
of her femur bone removed last year and
lung surgery just last week just gives
you an overview of where we're going
every day physical therapy
ginger
and i mean the schedule is full ginger's
appointments including physical therapy
can be up to an hour away from her home
in rural indiana surgeries can be more
than two hours away
before her diagnosis the water treatment
technician and nursing home worker lived
off of one tank of gas a week which cost
forty dollars they now need up to three
tanks a week to get to appointments
costing more than two hundred dollars
twenty dollars is only four gallons
after gas prices more than doubled in
the past year that's money they don't
always have so it's like you know let's
pay the mortgage first let's pay the
majority of the bills but the end of the
day i said wait a minute we do not have
money for gas you've been in that
situation oh yeah yeah so i end up like
going to instant cash that's our best
friend right now instant cash instant
cash those are short term high interest
loans they need to afford transportation
to ginger's appointments they've gotten
some help from co-workers ginger school
and ronald mcdonald house charities
which provide services for families of
sick children including housing near
hospitals this is ginger with the
charity's therapy dog gus
last year we were able to provide with
such high gas prices joanna sabato with
ronald mcdonald house says demand for
their services has surged beyond
capacity these families are really
having to ask themselves if both parents
can be by their child's bedside because
they can't afford to travel back and
forth because of the high gas prices
to try to cover the bills the vincents
have cut back on groceries a sacrifice
not lost on their daughter having to
watch them we have to pay this bill we
have to pay that and i'm downstairs and
i hear all of that it just seems so
stressful and i just feel bad for them
we're just hoping that one day you know
the government can do something about
this economy of about the gas prices
because they have the power we're fly
over country so if it doesn't hit new
york or washington or
california
they give you good lube service but they
don't really understand
the vincents say they're keeping their
eyes on what matters people have certain
bickerings
everyday trials
um rent food you know but you kind of
like work it out
when you get cancer that kind of stuff
pays away the big picture is her
this family is so
incredible the bond that they have how
they look after each other
you know they had to cut back on
groceries i mean we went to go shoot
that story they had a platter out for us
you know these are the type of people
that they are and they're in rural
america you heard the father say this is
flyover country but in in the midwest a
lot of agricultural areas you have to
travel to go to a big medical center but
they're also i'm thinking they're one
family their story's not unique just to
them there are other families like them
this is simply wrong this shouldn't be
happening and i was about to steal
people you mentioned that the gofundme
was boosted um yeah by the attention
which is wonderful and heartening but
then you're all sort of disheartened
that it takes yeah there are so many
people in the situation my husband deals
with heart transplant patients his
patients travel three hours just for
their regular appointments their
checkups which happen all the time
that's a lot of money on gas yeah it's a
great story